Now most famous as Netflix's surprise hit
of the 2019 holiday season, The Witcher started
life as a series of fantasy books and short
stories written by Polish author Andrzej Sapkowski.
The franchise's fortunes really took off in
2007, when game developers CD Projekt Red
produced the first of three smash hit video
games based on The Witcher.
It was in the games that Triss Merigold went
from a magic-wielding secondary character
lusting after the titular monster-slayer Geralt
to a magic-wielding major character and Geralt's
actual, though occasional, love interest.
In November 2018, British actress Anna Shaffer
was announced for the role in the Netflix
adaptation.
Given the character's contradicting history
between the page and the games, fans wondered
whether the Witcher writers would lean into
Triss' romance with Geralt on the series,
or return to the original text and sideline
her in favor of other characters.
On the first season of The Witcher at least,
it looked as though they were leaning more
towards the books, with Shaffer's Triss maintaining
a platonic-slash-professional relationship
with Geralt and ultimately working more closely
with the sorceress Yennefer.
"I enlisted a Witcher.
Geralt of Rivia.
I often wonder where fate took him."
"Somewhere unpleasant, I'm sure."
No matter what the Witcher team chose to do
with Triss Merigold for the show, one thing
is undeniable: the actress who plays her looks
incredibly familiar.
Here's where you may have seen Anna Shaffer
before.
Anna Shaffer's first-ever screen role was
in 2009's Harry Potter and the Half-Blood
Prince, in which she played a witch who couldn't
land her romantic interest.
Sound familiar?
In the David Yates-directed film, Shaffer
portrayed Gryffindor student Romilda Vane,
the leader of a clique of girls who become
obsessed with Harry, or, rather, with his
celebrity status, and trail him around Hogwarts
trying to get his attention.
In case you've forgotten the small details
from Harry Potter, Romilda Vane was a small
but memorable character in the fifth film.
Remember when Harry's best pal Ron Weasley
accidentally ate a Chocolate Cauldron laced
with love potion and became instantly infatuated
with a girl?
That girl was Romilda, who actually made the
love potion specifically for Harry.
Shaffer also appeared in the last two movies
of the franchise, 2010's Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows Part 1 and 2011's Part
2 continuation, but her character had a more
serious purpose throughout those installments.
Romilda joins Dumbledore's Army to fight against
the evil forces taking over the wizarding
world, but unlike many other minor characters,
she survives the Battle of Hogwarts that left
dozens dead.
Shaffer has a connection to another beloved
British-born franchise, one arguably even
more popular than Harry Potter and one that's
certainly been around for a lot longer.
The actress appeared briefly on Class, a Doctor
Who spin-off series written and created by
Patrick Ness.
The show centered around a group of teenagers
studying at Coal Hill Academy, a fictional
school that has popped up on numerous occasions
throughout Doctor Who, and the staff who worked
there.
On the series, which lasted only one season,
Shaffer played Rachel Chapman, the girlfriend
of main character Ram, who comes to a nasty
end, only for him to move on to another love
interest a couple of episodes later.
So much for the power of love.
Outside of worlds populated by witches, aliens,
and would-be girlfriends, Shaffer has mostly
been left with minor roles.
She had a blink-and-you'll-miss-it part in
the widely praised BBC drama Fearless in 2017,
and before The Witcher, she popped up in the
background of the forgettable British action
movie I Am Vengeance.
However, Shaffer managed to make a mark in
a super-melodramatic TV series.
She played yet another troublemaker with a
deeply hidden heart of gold when she took
on the role of rebellious bully Ruby Button
on the British daily soap opera Hollyoaks
from 2011 to 2014, returning for four guest
appearances in 2017 and 2018.
In typical soap fashion, Shaffer's Ruby went
through a lot during her brief stint on Hollyoaks:
a hit-and-run in which she was the passenger,
a foiled elopement that ended in her fiancé's
death, social exile on account of all the
bullying she'd masterminded, a cocaine-induced
heart attack, and a new life in Spain.
It almost makes dealing with the respective
armies of Voldemort, the Shadow Kin, and the
Nilfgaard seem like a cakewalk.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.